nuestra señora de la hora en la ciudad
antigua de mosúl
el dominico libio poquillo está a cargo
de este lugar este francés vivió aquí
entre 2003 y 2004 en 2019 regreso desde
la terraza del edificio nos recuerda que
mosúl la sunita también tiene un pasado
cristiano en un principio todo esto era
un barrio cristiano ahí podemos ver las
cruces de la iglesia de santo tomás
detrás la iglesia mis quinta y allá las
iglesias caldea de alta gira y siriaca
de alta gira caldean entre 2014 y 2017
el grupo estado islámico ocupó la ciudad
estos recintos fueron saqueados
profanados y mutilados
las cruces las quitaron las cúpulas
todavía están en pie
decimos que tuvimos suerte si comparamos
con otras iglesias salimos bien librados
por queda ese utilizo este lugar lo que
hizo que lo hayamos encontrado
deteriorado más no destruido
vine para nutrir aún hay marcas de los
terroristas en algunos de los muros del
convento obreros respaldados por la
unesco trabajan para borrar esa parte de
la historia antes de la llegada del papa
el primero y el segundo piso no están
despojados vale excavación y desminado
aún hay remanentes de la guerra
howse esto fue lo que encontramos en la
casa de oración son cinturones
explosivos
aquí hay fusiles granadas pistolas
androides
puesto
se abre otro capítulo de esta historia
ante los ojos de este guarda él forma
parte de las varias decenas de
cristianos que viven hoy en mosúl una
cifra muy lejana de los 45 mil que
vivían aquí en 2003 pasen hacia el mar
una parte de los cristianos no tiene
intención alguna de volver porque tienen
miedo aquí se vive en cohabitación algo
similar a lo que ocurría aquí antes de
2003 el alpe nuevo plata este cristiano
y estos musulmanes esperan que tanto sus
esfuerzos como la visita del papa den
pie para el retorno de las minorías
religiosas mientras eso ocurre ellos
siguen trabajando juntos para preservar
su herencia